the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi well I guess we're in the homestretch
of the course we're down to our last
concept and it will take us essentially
two lectures to cover this new concept
today we'll do the concept in general
and next time we'll apply it
specifically to the concept of series
but the concept that we want to talk
about is something called uniform
convergence let me say at the outset
that this is a very subtle topic it is
difficult it seems to be beyond the
scope of our textbook because it's not
mentioned there consequently I will try
to give the highlights as I speak with
you but that the supplementary notes
will contain a more detailed explanation
of the things that we're going to talk
about now to set the stage properly for
our discussion of uniform convergence I
think it's wise that we at least review
the concept of convergence in general
well let's take a look over here recall
that when we write that the limit of F
sub n of X as n approaches infinity
equals f of X for all X in the closed
and it will from A to B when this
happens another way of saying this is
that the sequence F sub n the sequence
of functions F sub n converges to the
function f on the closed interval from A
to B now again these tend to be words
unless you look at a specific example
let's just pick one over here let F sub
n of X be n over 2 n plus 1 times x
squared notice of course that the value
of this particular number depends both
on X and n okay at any rate let's leave
pick a fixed X hold it that way and take
the limit of F sub n of X as n
approaches infinity in other words as we
let n approach infinity in this case
notice that the limit of n over 2 n plus
1 becomes 1/2 X has been chosen
independently of the choice of n
consequently the limit function in this
case f of X is 1/2 x squared and in this
case what we say is that the sequence of
functions n x squared
over 2 and plus 1 converges to 1/2 x
squared now what does this mean more
specifically in other words let's see if
we can look at a few specific values of
X for example if I choose X to be 2 in
other words if I choose X to be 2 if we
look over here this says that F sub n of
X is 4 n over 2 n plus 1 if I now take
the limit as n approaches infinity I'm
going to wind up with what 1/2 X is
replaced by 2 2 squared is 4 1/2 of 4 is
2 in other words the limit of F sub n of
2 as n goes to infinity is 2 in a
similar way if I replace X by 4 1/2 x
squared becomes 8 and so what we have is
if the limit as n approaches infinity F
sub n of 4 is 8 the key thing being that
once you choose X notice that for a
fixed X F sub n of X is a constant and
you're now taking the limit of a
sequence of numbers you see at any rate
here is what the key point is what does
this mean by our basic definition by our
basic definition that means that we can
find the number capital M sub 1 such
that when n is greater than capital n
sub 1 the absolute value of F sub n of 2
minus 2 is less than Epsilon in a
similar way this means that we can find
a number that capital n sub 2 such that
for any N greater than capital n sub 2
the absolute value of F sub n of 4-8 is
also less than Epsilon the key point is
that N 1 and M 2 can be different in
other words you may have to go out
further to make this difference less
than Epsilon then you do to make this
difference less than Epsilon in other
words you see what's happening here and
we're going to review this in writing in
a few minutes so to see it in front of
you what happens here is that you see
that for different values of X we get
different values of N and since there
are infinitely many values of X it means
that in general we're going to be in a
little bit of trouble trying to find one
end that works for everything ok and let
me show you what that means again again
going more slow
I simply call this two basic definitions
in other words if we have a sequence of
functions F sub n each of which is
defined on the closed interval from A to
B we say that that sequence of functions
converges point-wise that means number
by number to F on a B if this limit F
sub n of X as n approaches infinity
equals f of X for each X and they be
okay in other words given epsilon
greater than 0 we can find n 1 such that
n greater than N 1 implies that the
absolute value of f sub n of X 1 minus f
of X 1 is less than Epsilon for a given
X 1 and a B in general the choice of n 1
depends on the choice of X 1 and there
are infinitely many such choices to make
in a B now the key point is this and
this is where uniform convergence comes
in if we can find one n such that
whenever little n is greater than that
capital n F sub n of X minus f of X in
absolute value is less than epsilon for
every X in the closed interval then we
say that the convergence is uniform in
other words if we can find one end that
makes that difference less than epsilon
for the entire interval then we call the
convergence uniform now you see
convergence in general is a tough topic
in particular uniform convergence may
seem even more remote and therefore what
I'd like to do now is saving the formal
proofs for the supplementary notes let
me show you pictorially just what the
concept of absolute form convergence
really is
see let me give you a pictorial
representation let's suppose I have the
curve y equals f of X now to be with an
epsilon of f of X means i retrace this
curve displaced epsilon units above the
original position and epsilon units
below in other words for a given epsilon
I now draw the curve y equals f of X
plus Epsilon and y equals f of X minus
Epsilon
now what uniform convergence means is
this that for this given epsilon I can
find the capital n such that whenever n
is greater than capital n the curve y
equals F sub n of X lies in this shaded
region in other words it can bounce
around all over but it can't get outside
of this region in other words once I'm
far enough out in my sequence all of the
curves lie in this particular region now
of course the question is what does this
all mean and the answer is well look at
let's take epsilon to be and I put this
in quotation marks very very small let's
pick epsilon for example to be so small
but it's within the thickness of our
truck if I now do this see I draw the
curve y equals f of X notice now that
the thickness of my curve itself is the
bandwidth - Epsilon all I'm saying is
that for this very very small Epsilon
when n is sufficiently large the curve y
equals F sub n of X appears to lie
inside of this curve you see in other
words what you're saying is is that for
large enough n and small enough Epsilon
loosely speaking what you're saying is
that y equals F sub n of X looks like y
equals f of X for sufficiently large
values of n in other words it appears
that we can't really tell why the enth
curve in the sequence from the limit
function and I want to make a few key
observations about what that means I've
written the whole thing out on the
blackboard search you can see this after
I say it but what I want you to see is
can you begin to get the feeling that
with this kind of a condition for
example
each F sub n happens to be continuous in
other words if each member of my
sequence is unbroken then the limit
function itself must also be unbroken
because you see I can squeeze this thing
down to such a narrow width that there's
no room for a break in here also notice
that if the curve y equals F sub n of X
is caught inside this curve if I for
example we're computing the area of the
region R for large enough n I couldn't
tell the difference in area if I use y
equals f of X for my top curve or
whether I use y equals F sub n of X
we'll keep that in mind and all I'm
saying is this that from our picture it
should seem clear that if the sequence F
sub n converges uniformly to F on a B
and if each F sub n is continuous on a B
then and this is a fundamental result
fundamental result 1 F is also
continuous on a B now you say look at
that's what you'd expect isn't it if
every member of the sequence is
continuous why shouldn't the limit
function also be continuous the point is
well maybe that's what you expect but
note this in one of our earlier lectures
we already saw that if we only had
point-wise convergence this did not need
to be true in particular recall our
example in which we defined f sub n of X
to be X to the N where the domain of F
was the clause of the rule from 0 to 1
remember what happened in that case each
of these F sub ends is continuous but
the limit function the limit function
you may recall is what it's 0 if X is
less than 1 1 if x equals 1 in other
words the limit function was
discontinuous at x equals 1 by the way
you might like to see what this means
from another point of view and let me
show you what it does mean from another
point of view since F continuous at x
equals x sub 1 means that the limit of f
of X as X approaches x1 is f of x1 and
since f of X itself by definition
is the limit of F sub n of X I guess as
n approaches infinity we may rewrite
first condition in the form what those
we may rewrite our first equation this
equation here in what form limit as X
approaches x1 absolute odd limit n
approaches infinity F sub n of X and
that equals the limit as n approaches
infinity F sub n of X 1 now keep in mind
that since each F sub n is given to be
continuous by definition of continuity F
sub n of X 1 is the same as saying the
limit as X approaches X 1 F sub n of X
the point I'm making is if you now put
this together with this it says the
rather remarkable thing that unless you
have uniform convergence when you
interchange the order in which you take
the limits over here you may very well
get a different answer in other words
when you're dealing with non-uniform
convergence you must be very very
careful to perform every operation in
the given order what we're saying is
what this will give you an answer this
will give you an answer but if the
convergence is not uniform the answers
may be different and consequently by
changing the order you destroy the whole
physical meaning of the problem well
again that's realized in the
supplementary notes let me continue on
here let me tell you another interesting
property of uniform convergence suppose
the sequence F sub n of X converges
uniformly to f of X on a be the point
that's rather interesting is that you
can reverse the order of integration and
taking the limit in this particular case
in other words suppose you want to
compute the integral of the limit
function from A to B what you can do
instead is compute the integral of the
nth member of your sequence and then
take the limit as n goes to infinity
in other words rewriting this it says
that if you have uniform convergence you
can take the limit inside the integral
sign and again these results are proven
in our supplementary notes we also say a
few words about corresponding results
for differentiation in our supplementary
notes and I should point out that
differentiation is a far more subtle
thing than integration you see remember
that the integration all you need is
continuity for differentiation you need
smoothness the point is that as you put
a thin band around the function y equals
f of X when you have uniform convergence
that's enough to make sure that the
limit function must be continuous if
each of the members in the sequence is
continuous but without going into the
details of this thing it does turn out
that for the degree of smoothness that
you need these things can jump around
enough so that for differentiation we do
have to be a little bit more careful
rather than to be cloud the issue I will
stick with integration topics for our
lecture today now the other thing that I
want to mention is again in terms of
doing what comes naturally I think we
are tempted to look at something like
this and say look at all I did was bring
the limit inside why can't I do that and
instead of saying look at you can't I
think the best thing to show is that
when you don't have uniform convergence
you get two different answers again the
idea being what we are not saying that
you can't do this we are not saying that
you can't compute this all we're saying
is that if the convergence is not
uniform these two expressions may very
well name different numbers now to show
you what I have in mind here let me give
you an example see to show you that two
need not be true if the convergence is
not uniform consider the following
example now in the supplementary notes I
repeat this example both the way I have
it on the board and also from an
algebraic point of view without using
the pictures but in terms of a picture
here's what we do we define a function
on the closed interval from zero to two
which I'll call f
as follows for a given n I will locate
the points one over n and two over N for
example if n happened to be 50 this
would be one fiftieth and this would be
250th now what I do is I at the x-value
1 over n I take as the corresponding
y-value and squid and I draw the
straight line that goes from the origin
to this point 1 over N comma and squid
then I draw the straight line that comes
right back through the x-intercept 2
over N and I finish off the curve by
just letting it hug the x-axis till we
get over to x equals 2 I'll come back to
this on the next board to show you why I
chose this but let's make a few
observations just to make sure that you
understand what this function looks like
I'll just make a few arbitrary remarks
about it first of all for each N F sub n
of 1 over N is N squared that's just
another way of indicating a label for
this point secondly my claim is that for
any number X sub 0 if X sub 0 is greater
than 2 over n F sub n of X 0 must be 0
and the reason for that is quite simple
if you just trying to show you how to
read this picture namely notice that as
soon as X gets to be as great as 2 over
n the F value is 0 because the function
is hugging the x axis and this is a
final observation notice that when X sub
0 is 0 F sub n of 0 is 0 for every n
meaning that every member of my family
of functions goes through this
particular point in other words let me
just label this this is y equals F sub n
of X ok well by the way if F sub n of 0
is 0 for each n in particular the limit
of F sub n of 0 as n approaches infinity
is 0 what happens if we pick a nonzero
value for example suppose I pick x0 to
be greater than 0 but less than or equal
to 2 the key point is this that since
the
are 2 over n as n approaches infinity is
0 given a value of x0 which is not 0 I
can find the capital n such that when n
is greater than capital n 2 over n is
less than X 0 in other words if X 0 is
greater than 0 and 2 over n approaches 0
for large enough values of N 2 over n
will be less than X 0 in particular when
that happens if we couple this with our
earlier observation what earlier
observation well this one if we couple
that with our earlier observation we see
that when n is greater than capital n F
sub n of X 0 is 0 correspondingly then
the limit of F sub n of X 0 as n
approaches infinity by definition is 0
in other words I'm going to reinforce
this later
but notice that the limit function here
is the function which is identically 0
now since this may look very abstract to
you let me take a few minutes and I hope
this doesn't insult your intelligence
but let me just take a few minutes and
redraw this for a couple of different
values of n just so as you can see
what's starting to happen here okay keep
that picture in mind and now look what
this means for example when n is 1 1
over N is 1 2 over N is 2 and squared is
1 in other words the graph y equals f1
of X is just this triangular this well
just this Y give it a name well let's
try a tougher one let's see what the
member F sub xx looks like recall how
you draw this now with the subscript xx
what do you do you come into the point 1
over 20 okay and at that point you do
what you locate the point 1 over 20
comma and squared in this case is 400
and I have obviously haven't drawn this
to scale but you now do what draw the
straight line that goes from the origin
to this point then from this point you
draw the straight line that comes back
to the x-axis hitting that x equals
1:10 and then you come across the x-axis
all the way to X equals 2 this would be
the graph of y equals F sub xx of X and
by the way these sense what's happening
over here
see notice that as n gets very very
large as n gets very very large the
curve hugs the x axis starting in closer
and closer to the y axis but what
happens is you see is someplace in here
no matter how close X sub zero is to
zero there comes a very high peak in
fact what is that high peak it's N
squared in other words when this number
is very close to the y axis the peak is
very very high in other words no matter
how you put the squeeze on over here
this particular peak jumps out this is
why this particular sequence of
functions is not uniformly convergent
again this is done more slowly in the
notes but at any rate let me show you an
interesting thing that happens over here
but let me redraw this now for a general
n in other words let me draw y equals F
sub n of X for any old n recall what our
definition was now especially with this
is review we locate the point 1 over N
comma and squid we then draw the line
that goes from the origin to that point
then we draw the line that goes from
that point back to the x-axis at the
point 2 over N and then we come across
to x equals 2 let's try to visualize
what the integral from zero to two F sub
n of xdx means after all in the case of
a continuous curve which this is isn't
the definite integral interpreter just
as the area under the curve well you see
the curve coincides with the x axis from
2 over N on to 2 consequently this
triangular region which I call R is the
area under the curve in other words the
integral from 0 to 2 F sub n of xdx is
the area of the region R but here's the
point we can compute the area of the
region R very easily it's a triangle
right what is the area of a triangle
well it's 1/2 times the base but the
base is just 2 over N
time's the height the highest and squid
in other words the area of the region
are simply is n and that's rather
interesting in other words for each n
this particular integral just turns out
to be n itself that's what's interesting
about this particular diagram in other
words this thing Rises so high that even
though the base gets very very small as
n gets large the height increases so
rapidly that the area under this curve
numerically is always equal to n ok in
fact we can check that if you'd like
come back to this particular case look
at this particular triangle the basis to
the height is 1 the area is 1 unit look
at this particular triangle the base is
1/10
the height is 400 400 times 1/10 is 40
and half of that is 20 the area of this
triangle is 20 which exactly matches the
subscript that's what's going to happen
here all the time in particular then if
we compute the integral from 0 to 2 F of
n X DX and then let the limit as n goes
to infinity be computed what do we get
for an answer we get that this limit is
the limit of n as n approaches infinity
and that of course is infinity on the
other hand suppose we bring the limit
inside in other words suppose we compute
this well the point is that we have
already shown that this is identically 0
for all X consequently this integral is
the integral from 0 to 2 0 DX which is 0
in other words if you first take the
limit and then integrate you get 0 on
the other hand if you first integrate
and then take the limit you get infinity
and this should be a glaring example to
show you that the answer that you get
indeed does depend on the order in which
you do the operations again let me
emphasize which of these two is wrong
the answer is neither is wrong all we're
saying is that if you were supposed to
solve this
and by mistake you solve this one you
are going to get a drastically different
answer okay let's not beat this to death
so far so good let me make one more
remark namely what does all of this have
to do with the study of series see now
we're just talking about sequences of
functions and you see the answer to this
question is essentially going to be the
lecture our last lecture of the course
you see but for now what I'd like to do
is to give you a preview of that namely
the application of uniform convergence
the series is the following recall that
when we write summation n goes from 0 to
infinity a star then X to the N that's
an abbreviation for what a polynomial K
goes from 0 to n a sub K X sub K as n
goes to infinity
in other words recall that the sum of
the series is a limit of a sequence of
partial sums and this is the nth member
of that sequence of partial sums again
if this Sigma notation is strong new off
all I'm saying is that to observe that a
0 plus a 1 X plus a 2 x squared plus etc
etc etc forever
just represents the limit of the
following sequence a 0 next member is a0
plus a1x next member is a0 plus a1x plus
a2x squared the next member is a0 plus
a1x plus a2x squared plus a3 X cubed by
the way what is each member of the
sequence it's a polynomial and
polynomials have very nice properties
while among which are what well a
polynomial is a continuous function a
polynomial is an integral function etc
the idea therefore is that if this
sequence of partial sums converges
uniformly to the limit function then for
example the limit function namely the
power series must be continuous since
each partial sum that makes up the
sequence of partial sums
is also continuous namely every
polynomial is continuous also if for
some reason or other you want to
integrate that power series from A to B
if the convergence is uniform I can then
do what I can then take the summation
sign outside integrate the nth partial
sum and add these all up you see the
idea being what that the M part of sum
is a polynomial and a polynomial is a
particularly simple thing to integrate
that's one of the easiest functions to
integrate in fact okay now here's the
wrap-up then what we shall show next
time is that within the interval of
absolute convergence the sequence of
partial sums which we already know
converges absolutely to the limit
function also converges uniformly in
other words within the radius of
convergence the power series and I don't
know how to say this other than to say
it enjoys the usual polynomial
properties associated with a polynomial
such as summation K goes from 0 to n a
sub K X to the K in other words then
this about wraps us wraps up what our
introductory lecture for today wanted to
be namely the concept of uniform
convergence what I would like you to do
now is to study this material very
carefully in the supplementary notes go
over the learning exercises so that you
become familiar with this then we will
wrap up our course in our next lecture
when we show what a very very powerful
tool the particular this particular
concept of absolute convergence is in
the study of mathematical the
mathematical concept of convergence at
any rate until next time then goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate